y tiempo de hablar de economía en france
24 y estamos para eso con nuestra
compañera daniela que nos va a contar lo
más importante de hoy daniele empezamos
hablando de las mujeres en américa
latina' que perdieron una década de
avances en materia laboral o la de
liliana para nadie es un secreto que en
américa latina' siempre ha sido dispar
la participación de mujeres y hombres en
el mercado laboral pero con la pandemia
la situación es todavía más grave cada
vez es menos el porcentaje de la
población femenina que está en edad y
condiciones de trabajar de acuerdo con
la comisión para américa latina y el
caribe las cifras dan cuenta de la
situación liliana la tasa de desempleo
de las mujeres de la pandemia se disparó
del 96 por ciento al 12% mientras que la
de los hombres todavía permanece en un
dígito muchas de ellas no han retomado
la búsqueda de empleo porque tienen el
deber de dedicarse al cuidado de sus
hogares según este organismo escuchemos
qué significa esto significa que 23
millones de mujeres se visionan a la
pobreza vamos a tener 118 millones de
mujeres en situación de pobreza y esta
cifra de 118 millones de mujeres de la
pobreza la estamos tomando con base en
si no hay medidas
daniela y eeuu tardará en recuperarse en
temas de empleo según la reserva federal
de este país bueno el presidente de la
reserva federal de eeuu reveló que el
hecho de que la tasa de desocupación
esté ahora por debajo del 6 o del 7 por
ciento no quiere decir necesariamente
que haya una gran mejoría respecto de
todo lo que se ha perdido en la pandemia
esto sucede porque hay 4 millones de
personas desempleadas que han dejado de
buscar trabajo y esto de inmediato hace
que no se cuenten como desempleados
puesto la tasa de desempleo real es
cercana al 10 por ciento si se incluyen
las personas que abandonaron la fuerza
laboral la economía está muy lejos de
nuestras metas de empleo e inflación y
es probable que se tarde algún tiempo en
lograr un progreso sustancial libre
daniela y el parlamento europeo dio luz
verde al millonario fondo de
recuperación esta es liliana un amplio
paquete de 670 y 2.500 millones de euros
en préstamos y subvenciones para que los
países miembros puedan recuperarse más
rápidamente de la crisis originada por
la pandemia del coronavirus sin embargo
que haya sido aprobado no significa que
los recursos vayan a ser entregados pues
esto tardará unos meses primero los
países ascienden hasta abril para hacer
una propuesta oficial sobre en qué se
van a gastar esos recursos ya 18 de
ellos lo han hecho después del proyecto
se somete país por país a la comisión
europea este organismo es el que al
final del proceso se va a encargar de
tomar préstamos en los mercados
financieros mundiales para cumplir con
el objetivo de todos sus miembros que es
salir de la crisis
danielle hay una importante revista
regresa a wall street' de cual se trata
playboy
liliana que volverá a tocar la campana
de la bolsa de nueva york este jueves
después de nueve años de ausencia está
la historia en 2011 dejó de cotizar en
bolsa tras un acuerdo
que hizo su fundador el fallecido hugh
hefner con una firma de capital privado
por 207 millones de dólares desde
entonces las ventas cayeron en picada
cuando en la década del 70 en pleno
apogeo vendía 7 millones de ejemplares
la pandemia hizo que hace un año una de
las revistas de hombres son más
populares del mundo dejará de imprimirse
así se puso fin a una publicación de
casi siete décadas que comenzó en 1953
con marilyn monroe en su portada no está
claro si vuelve o no a la publicación
pero ahora es mucho más que eso
ya no somos una empresa de medios encima
de productos de consumo organizados en
torno a cuatro multimillonarios
categorías estas cuatro categorías son
bienestar sexual indumentaria juegos
estilo de vida belleza y cuidado
personal manera cuéntenos cómo están los
indicadores de la jornada bueno o street
cerró mixto y el récord de hoy fue para
el índice dow jones de industriales-
los mercados europeos operaron por su
parte a la baja en medio de la
revelación de datos económicos poco
alentadores en alemania
las bolsas de américa latina por su
parte cerraron casi todas en rojo y
hablamos ahora la cifra del día daniel a
los 248 millones de dólares en pérdidas
que tuvo la reconocida cervecera
holandesa heineken en 2020 esto les
llevó a anunciar que va a recortar 8.000
empleos en todo el mundo y liliana esto
representa un 10 por ciento de su fuerza
laboral global gracias están hablando
nuestra periodista experta en temas de
economía y ustedes también gracias por
estar entrada 24 continúen con más
temprando 24 punto com
[Música]